hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome to episode 110 of game
programming today we're going to talk
about getting uh basically being able to
enter some kind of text uh into our
little render method here and then based
on what text that is of course we will
render the appropriate characters from
our character array okay so in case you
guys have been living under a rock and
missed all the other episodes go watch
them but
uh we have a basically any any any kind
of character we want to show up we can
now actually control that right so if i
go ahead and
uh print like this one for example you
can see it's printing f okay and f is
index five why because f of course is
the sixth letter in the alphabet but
more importantly the reason that's
actually happening is if i just bring
this up really quickly here
um
the idea is let me just find my little
font sheet uh the idea is of course in
our actual font shape which you guys can
actually find i'll make a link in the
description so that you guys can
actually download that font sheet if you
want the exact same one one that i have
but um essentially in this phone sheet
right we have
uh a b c d e f g h i j k anyway we've
got all this well like this array
basically of um
of characters okay and the idea is um
based on
the
index of each character
that's what's going to define which one
gets rendered right of course if i go
ahead and say a b okay let's say uh i
want to render the letter n okay well we
know there are 13 characters here okay
array started 0 so this n here is going
to be number 13 okay so if i switch back
into our code and i type in 13 over here
and i hit debug we should get n and you
can see we do
okay
zero of course
would be
uh a
right and then because since we know
that one row is essentially uh 13
characters wide we can do something like
13 times zero of course which will if
obviously be zero but uh if i do it the
other way around um
we've got uh zero okay it's like this
this is like the row okay so row zero
we get a
right uh if we go row one
we will get n okay
uh let's spice it up a bit and say this
so this is row zero one two three four
say row four if i go row four right what
is it gonna give me it should give me
zero right and you can see it does okay
so basically the idea is we need some
way
to be able to pick out a certain
character but
but the big thing here is that the
character that we pick out
really has to depend on text that we
input okay so first of all we need a way
to actually tell our program oh hey you
know this is the character at this index
we kind of need a way to map out these
characters and the way that we can do
that is by literally making a string
in our font class that contains
these characters in order okay so what
i'm going to do now right if i alt tab
back into our code i'm going to make a
private static this will not change at
least for now
private because we've only got one font
uh private static string i'll call this
characters okay
um and this will uh it will not be an
array notice it's just a normal string
okay and these characters are literally
just going to be all of these so
beginning with capital letters of course
a b c d e f g h
oops h i j k l m n and then we kind of
get to n and it's like well this string
will be very long first of all
and b
we kind of you know it's going to be
kind of hard to diagnose where we went
wrong so basically the idea is we want
to kind of format it so that
um
after m you know we can kind of hit
enter and start off on a new row okay
so kind of like that this is kind of
what we want to do and eclipse actually
does a bit of this for us but the idea
is what we want to do is split up our
string into several different
strings just to make it easier for us to
read okay the computer's going to read
it the same way but what i'm going to do
is i'm going to hit up plus
then a double like a double forward
slash to indicate a comment and then i'm
going to continue typing over here so
for example n
okay
let's cut that just for now i've already
got characters here i just noticed that
okay um
oops i'll call it
uh character index okay okay so why have
i done this and what is this plus and
what is this
double little comma sign okay now the
reason i've done this right and this
will actually get formatted over here
but don't worry about that just for now
um the reason i've done this is because
first of all we want to drop this into a
new row okay the plus works just the way
it would if this was here okay it's the
same thing as if we did plus two for a
string right it would just append two
onto the end of the string that is what
happens with n and gets appended onto
the end of this string okay
now
if i hit enter and i hit ctrl shift f to
format our code eclipse is going to pull
that back up why that's just eclipse's
order formatting rules okay you can
probably fix that up but an easy way to
do that is to simply
hit up a double forward slash and then
drop that into another row now why will
it not bring up n it can't because if it
does n becomes a comment and it's no
longer code okay so that's why eclipse
is not bring it up and doing it this way
is really really easy okay so i can put
a doubles equal a double kind of comma
sign here drop this down here and then
what we'll get is
everything on a new string for
everything on on a new line for example
okay so it's really up to you how you
format this but i like doing it this way
so let's continue here so we've got n
it just kind of makes it like
aesthetically to us as programmers look
a bit better because
you know hey we can see
uh the n is on a separate row okay so
i'll continue here
n o p q r s t u v w x y and z okay
fantastic so then i'll do the same thing
plus four slash fold slash and then i'll
keep going right and the idea is if i
hit ctrl shift f and i won't do that now
but i will in a minute you'll see that
it will more or less uh not get
formatted back up to the line so a b c d
e f g h i don't need to keep checking
that
jk l m okay
plus
no p q r s
t u v
uh w x y and z okay fantastic now
um
okay so what i'm gonna do now is let me
just bring that back up
okay
so then what do we have then we've got
the numbers now so zero one two three
four five six seven eight nine and then
we've got dot
uh dot
uh comma and
one of these
apostrophe single quote whatever you
wanna call that
um and then we've got
uh another single okay this is where it
gets interesting okay because we've got
two types of single quotes notice and
then we've got two types of these things
now what i want to do here is i'm
actually not going to
add the real quotes okay so basically
you can see that this is not a neutral
so to say quote it's an opening quote
and this is a closing quote okay for now
i'm not going to look up the ascii table
and find out what they actually are okay
because in eclipse since eclipse is an
editor for code if you hit
uh these apostrophes or
you know the single or double quotes
they're going to be neutral okay they're
not going to be facing any direction
okay otherwise the code will not get
passed correctly um that's why eclipse
and any other
uh text editor will do that but if you
go into something like word
um in fact
i'll much do that now because you guys
will probably want to see that
if i go into something like microsoft
word
all right
uh and then i go ahead and say
uh opening quote or whatever you can see
it's going to bring it up as an actual
opening quote okay and a closing chord
and same thing with this so if i grab
this and i put it into eclipse you can
see oh look they look very different
don't they okay so you could do it this
way um in fact i probably will now that
i've done anyway so apostrophe
uh this is this is really an opening
quote okay so i'll just um
now the downside however if you do that
is that you're not going to be you're
going to have to basically copy and
paste it every time you want that okay
so you could do it this way um and i've
kind of shown you how but i've just
decided i'm not going to do it this way
okay so that's how you get those
characters in eclipse you can just do do
it in microsoft word or whatever and
then just copy and paste it and it'll
work but um we're not going to use them
okay we're going to use standard quotes
so we've got an opening court
so to speak we've got closing quote
they're the same though then we've got
an opening double quote and a closing
double chord how we do how do we do that
we can't just do double quote because as
you can see it will actually close off
the string right
to do characters like that you can hit
backslash and then the character so
basically backslash
uh this apostrophe sorry backslash
double quote will literally just be a
double quote okay but of course we can't
actually add a double quote because that
would end our string since double quotes
are what we use over here right so
that's what we can do so we'll just do
two of these whoops
and then everything else should work
fine okay you can see that works
now i've hit ctrl shift f and it's
formatted it but you can see it's nice
and it's row by row it is a bit offset
but that's alright i'm not gonna fix
that right now you can if you go into uh
the eclipse eclipses formatting settings
there are i know that for a fact there
are settings to control indentation so
you could control it that way but i'm
not gonna bother with that right now
because it looks fine to me all right
great so we've got the apostrophes now
we've got the semicolon and the colon
semicolon colon
uh x mark at sign dollars percentage
uh what else
brackets
minus plus all right fantastic that's it
that's all we need so the idea is i've
copied down this font shade exactly make
sure it's obviously correct otherwise
it's not going to work okay but this is
how we do it okay simple as that we've
got this now now how is this useful to
us
very very it's the the reason it's
simple
sorry the reason it's uh actually useful
to us it's very very simple okay
because this
is like a lookup table
when we pass in a string to render such
as hello okay what we're going to be
able to do is say
okay
find the letter h
in this index
okay
uh here it is capital h there it is okay
then we can say well what position is
that in this index what index is it in
this string okay zero one two three four
five six seven it's index seven okay
thus i'm going to use index seven
for the array and if i launch this and
run it
h we get an h okay that's how it works
and then it will repeat the same thing
for e l l and then o okay
that's how it works so we have a lookup
table and conveniently the reason i did
these in order obviously is that this
lookup table corresponds directly to
which character is which in our sprite
array okay simple as that now
in order to actually
calculate all these indexes uh
our our job is largely made easy because
there is an actual um there's an actual
uh
method in the string class that will
actually find
what index a character is at but
essentially what we need to do is
obviously we want to render every single
character
okay if we type in a message and we
could probably do this right now so font
uh so public word render for example
here might have something like
uh
you know string text okay
so that's very very simple but the idea
is we want to render every single
character in this string that we passed
not just the first one okay so we're
going to need a way to repeat code we're
going to need some kind of loop okay
a good way to go would probably be a for
loop okay
because
um
strings are indexed as well so picture a
string is an array of characters because
that's really what it is okay in fact
you can see over here
uh it represents character strings okay
um
and the idea is uh
here we go exactly string string equals
abc
the actual character data is just an
array abc okay that's how it works
so it is an array of characters that we
have so let's let's go through every
index in that array or in other words
say in i equals zero i is less than text
dot length because we're going through
every
not last index
i did a lot uh because we're going
through every single
um
character in that array i plus plus okay
we'll get we'll grab the character
uh and we'll just call it current
character okay and that will be
text dot
character at
and then of course the index being i
alright
so
what does this do pretty simple
if we go ahead and print
current character
all right
and i won't actually print it on new
line
all right i'll pop in a new line at the
end of this though so it prints it all
in a row um and i might actually just
print it along with a space okay if i go
to game fix up this error enter
something like
hello
all right and then i just run this
basically what we're going to get is you
can see hello okay the reason they have
spaces in between them of course is
because i did put that space
over here but you can see that by this
for loop it just is rendering every
single character individually all right
if i do put a
line at the end of that
enter on this
then we're obviously going to get hello
okay
so that's how that works pretty simple
right again if you guys are ever in
doubt at what something does print it to
the console that's probably the best
debugging tool you actually have okay
obviously debuggers are very powerful
but this printing to the console thing
it it's just probably the easiest way
honestly all right fantastic so now that
we've got that we need to figure out
which index this character is in our
string right so how do we do that well
let's make a variable out of it and
let's set it equal to
our character index right
dot index of and then we can pass in a
character for example
current character
all right
so if now we were to print out
um
index
plus maybe like a space right
and we run this
all right so let's just add in a
print line at the end of that
um if we run that there you go all right
great so we're getting
all the indexes now so you can see for
the first one it's saying
all right well
the first one
right over here is of course the letter
h
and what is it giving us
it's giving us seven why seven
well
zero one two three four five six seven
right h is number seven then it's giving
us number 30 which i presume is
lowercase
um
e i'm not going to count that but that's
the idea and all the way to 70 being the
explanation mark which is right over
here all right fantastic so guess what
we've now got an index so now all we
really need to do is actually render the
sprite for each of the characters and
which index are we going to render it at
index okay
simple as that so if we do this now what
are we getting exclamation mark wait
that's weird shouldn't we get the whole
world word well obviously but the idea
is that we're all printing them on top
of each other the last one is
exclamation mark okay so if i do
something like a single character print
so for example i can print like an
number two run this sweet we get two
change this to a lowercase a like i say
how awesome is that right it's doing
everything for us except it's not
printing them in a row how do we do that
well we need to play around with the
position that we rendered the sprite out
okay
now how big are these i've actually
forgotten which is a bit embarrassing i
think they're 16 by 16 though so what i
can do is if i put
uh let's just say
uh we'll go 50 for now so 50 right now
okay i'll change these two parameters in
a minute but just to not complicate this
50 50 is kind of the index that we want
to render it out okay so right right now
that's over here okay now based on which
character we're currently rendering it
at right because of course i know the
length of the string and that then i'm
obviously using this for loop to go
through every character in the string
based on which character i'm up to
that's the x position it should have
right so the first one again should be
offset by nothing the second one should
be offset by 16 the third one by 32 then
48 and 64. so on okay
so how can i do that i can say plus i
being this current
variable here right with which iteration
of the forward we're up to multiplied by
16 because that is the size of each
character all right let's launch this
and see what happens
amazing
there's our text awesome isn't it so now
if i change this to something like
the churno
what's going to happen
we're going to crash why did we crash
why did we crash
because i put a space there
all right so what happens if there's a
space
what do we do if there's a space
well it's pretty obvious what we do okay
we still increment
the position that i'm at
but we don't render anything there
okay
so
put it to put it simply right now what
we'll do is because if if it can't find
it i think it returns negative one
yeah negative one if the character does
not occur okay so we could put in like a
space as putting a space here will not
work by the way because since we don't
have it in our actual characters thing
it'll still give us an array index out
of bounds because that will be
number it'll be basically be at um
at the lot like past the last uh index
of our um characters array okay so what
we can do
um is simply say well for now i could
just say if
index uh equals negative one continue
all right not a solution but we'll think
of one in a minute okay and for that it
will still
put a space there but it will not um
crash or anything so that works fine
okay so i can put literally anything
here and it will work okay anything that
any any kind of character that exists in
here will work out all right
so that being said where is that
where's that game
um i mean let's try a few right so let's
put in
like quotes perhaps if you're doing
quotes make sure you have a backslash
there
otherwise it will think you're ending
the string you can see that does not
work
awesome we've got quotes they are
beginning quotes but that's all right
um you can change that in the actual
sheet if you want there's no actual way
to get closing quotes right again i i
said as i said before
uh there is a way right if i go into
word again
grab these guys put them here make an
opening make it an opening and a closing
quote
and then uh over here in
let me just grab them again over here in
font
i can of course
do the same thing here so we have where
are they oops
instead of these backslash things i'll
just have that if i run this now
look at that we're getting our opening
and we're getting our closing but the
thing is it's a lot of work to copy and
base them so it's up to you what you
guys choose of course but that is the
idea so now we have pretty much full
text rendering going on okay now there
are problems and we're going to fix them
in the upcoming two episodes we're going
to spend two more episodes on this font
and everything uh hopefully not more
than that but the idea is we have a few
problems for example if we put something
like
uh let's put something in like uh
game with lowercase g
or gaming what's going to happen
the g is going to be kind of pushed up
and the y is going to be pushed out it
just looks weird right we don't want
that so we'll that's one thing we need
to fix then the other thing we need to
fix is of course
making spaces proper but that's a minor
thing the other major thing we need to
fix is this pink background okay we want
to get rid of that so those are the two
things we're going to fix in upcoming
episodes but i hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of game programming if you
did please hit that like button um
now what else what else i think there's
any really announcements to make um i'm
going to try and make more episodes i
always say that but i'm being serious
this time if you guys do want to learn
uh privately from me if you go to my
website the channel.com there is a
tutoring section if you go to that you
can pick a time at which i am available
which is in australianness and standard
time uh fill out the form and i will get
back to you shortly and basically you
can book a tutorial with me privately
all right over skype and i will explain
to you whatever it is you wish to know
anyway that is the idea
uh if you guys are enjoying the game
programming series please hit the like
button the more likes i get the more
episodes i know i should push the more
time i should allocate to this basically
is that's my thought process
um obviously if you know if heaps of
people want me to do it then i'm here so
that's the idea anyway i'll see you guys
next time goodbye
you